（僕の名前は、はじめしゃちょー）
（最近、バスケットボールにはまっているんだ）
（どうだい僕のボール捌き）
（場所がないから股ばっかりボール通してるけど気にしないでくれ）
うめー
バスケットゴールを作ろうと思います
薄々気づいてたんですけど
僕のできるスポーツはバスケットしかないんですよ
運動しなきゃと思ってきまして 家でバスケットボール
家でバスケットボールしたいなと思ったので
ボールは買ったんですけどボールでこうやってても
実践的な練習にはならないので
今回、家に
割とガッツリ
こちら！
プルル～～ンシュコ～～（ヒカキンさんのマネ）
はいというわけで
家にバスケットゴールがあればシュート練習もドリブルもできるわけですよ
まじで本格的にバスケットボールを家で始めたいんですけど
体育館に行くのも面倒くさいし
家の近くに体育館がないので
今回、バスケットゴールを家に買いました
一人暮らしの家でバスケットゴール買う奴なんてそういないから
割と今回歴史的になる試みになると思う
さあ開けてきましょう
一応、完成図はこんな感じですね
普通にバスケットはできます
うっっわ
リングだ
わかんない
よくわかんない×3
えーこれひょっとして大変かな
えー待って作るの大変そうなんだけど
よーし、なんとしても僕は家でバスケットボールがしたい
今日はなんとしてでもバスケットゴールを作ります
ではいこう！
あっつｨ
作る前から経験的にわかるんですけどバスケットゴールって難しいんですよ
ほら、大人2名以上でやってください
3名推奨
1人でやってやんよ
*組み立て中*
これを入れれば
あっ
*悲しげな音楽*
はいというわけで、地下倉庫なら多分作れると思うので
地下倉庫でバスケットゴールを作ります
全然高さ考えてなかったので
これだけ高さあれば絶対作れると思うので
高さがないとバスケできないので地下で作ります
では
うわあああやばいやばいホントやばい
ンアーーッやばい
よっしゃOK OK OK
よし、完成かもしれません
はいというわけで無事バスケットボール完成しました
では
バスケットゴール立たせます
いくぞー
いくぞ
*悲しげな音楽*
待って待って待って待って
逆に
こうやって
こっち立たせればいく気がする
あ、立った！立ったー
立ったよー
はいというわけで無事バスケットゴールが完成しました
これで僕は
いつでもバスケットボールができる
シュート練習できるのはかなり僕嬉しいです
では最初の1本目いきます
*枢軸国のマークのようなバスケットゴール*